to the sky I'm counting down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
feels like I've been walking
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy Monday we worked so hard last week
just to get to Friday and then three
seconds later it's back Monday look why
is that fair it's not fair but the
weekend was very rewarding I felt I felt
very rested oh that's nice I do not
because I worked Friday night and I got
home at 3 in the morning so I was like
so tired and slept and then Saturday
night I got drunk so I guess left like
[ __ ] Saturday night like it's just so
hard when you need to make the most of
your weekends in terms of like relaxing
partying and having a social life and
then also working like we do know I I
felt as though I balanced everything
really well cuz I had a social life I
saw my friends I breasted a lot I
watched the whole new season of
Riverdale so good by the way so good is
over Riverdale like you know they had me
season one ain't easy to like I was
there even though we all knew it was bad
it's just like I'm at a place in my life
you know I was just having this
conversation with a friend of mine like
where I'm like cutting our toxic like
people and like things that just don't
like that if it mean like that as TV
shows to like I think I dare but this
new I really love Riverdale and I would
I watched it even when I totally didn't
like get the subject matter but it's
paying off this season because there's
like it's all good the relationships are
good end games are strong and like the
drama is more believable than ever right
I'm good you know and I'm happy for
everyone who's enjoying the season I'm
just really like at a place in my life
where I just I'm cutting out things that
like don't greatly behoove me okay you
know that's that sounds great except
that you watch marriage story yesterday
so I well I watch my own story for a
multitude of reasons one I think it's
part of my job to speak on what's going
viral like everyone is talking about
marriage story I deliver have seen you
have seen so many memes back the one
name at the drunk on everyone that's
talking about it and then I really want
to talk to Scarlett Johansson on
Saturday Night Live
but I thought there might be like skits
referencing it and I just thought it
would behoove me to watch it in full see
what all the hype was about and it kind
of looked good like just from what I had
seen of it but now having seen it I
don't know if I would use the word good
you know yeah I'm definitely intense
yeah this is what it is I'm glad that I
watched it because like I said
everyone's talking about it like I might
watch Bird box when everyone was talking
about it and like I should just be like
watching things people are talking about
it's literally my job it's that we do
that most of the
I many much prayer box either and I feel
great about the decision yeah but like I
did not understand any of the means okay
but it's my job to understand the meme
so I watched it and here's my thought
process reminded me of the irishman
pretty much to a tee
way too long I'm great actors great
acting but like really not sure why the
movie was made because there was no
climax oh no peak no real storyline so
reminded me of that um I thought the
acting was superb
I think Adam driver is like the scariest
like actor ever like he's so serious in
Scarlett Johansson was amazing like I
didn't like her haircut the home with me
so it's really frustrating and from what
I've gathered from people who have
watched it and have been divorced
apparently the movie is like a replica
of what it feels like to get divorce
like the like the depression like and
all the different emotions and then the
custody like people who weren't having
me when I was talking about her they
were like it was so depressing but like
that's exactly what it was like for me
so I think the whole point of the movie
was to be like a real human experience
about going through a divorce in two
hours I understand um I didn't really
know that's what I was getting on board
you know of watching and I don't really
know that I want to know what it's like
to get divorced because I'm going on a
theme park ride where you experience a
divorce and I have I have no plans on
being divorced I guess nobody has plans
you know I'm getting divorced but I
really have no plans I'm getting
divorced so I just um like I said you
know GLAAD should support Scarlett
Johansson because after watching that so
now I stand harder than ever we'll get
to it so now I guess I'm just like a
Scarlett Johansson mm-hmm and I watch
all the crap she does because that's
what I did yesterday whole day with
Scarlett Johansson and I would have been
annoyed if I just watched marriage story
but then I finished with SNL and I was
like so like the circle was complete I
understand we'll get to SNL speaking of
great movies you want to know what I saw
this weekend frozen - Oh a we're each
two billion dollars in the box office
very I'm very happy for them you know I
will say though it was a great movie
obviously the frozen team knows what
they're doing but I found the storyline
to be very confusing and it's a I don't
understand how the campers were able to
keep up by the end they bring it full
circle in the end it's fabulous and it
makes the movie great but throughout I
was just like this is really complex
stuff but you know what's funny as you
like you learn as an adult is that kids
movies like that you watched as a kid
like they have two movies going on a
movie for the children and then there's
like some jokes that go above the
children I just wasted them your watch
Shrek
very inappropriate
I understand it but I'm not like and I
think don't love like at the children's
house just the storyline like it was
just confusing her on I found and snitch
was confused too
but but it was great and the music was
great and I highly recommend it and then
my mind should the unknown is gonna win
the Golden Globe um no I think it's too
competitive this year I don't think it's
achieved what let it go has achieved and
you know that actually isn't even my
favorite song from the movie the one
will show yourself that's the song you
guys I wonder why they didn't have a
contemporary artist cover it because
right look at Jimmy Lovato again um and
then I watched another fabulous movie
called same time next Christmas with Lea
Michele Oh ABC original mm-hmm okay
they've been pruning it so much and you
know me I'm like anything lay Michele's
I was like I'll watch even if it's a
piece of Duty being set on fire how was
it it was wonderful I by the way when I
was watching marriage story like so many
people were like no don't watch it watch
the Lea Michele Christmas movie yeah
that's the marriage story that I want to
say yeah it was wonderful it had all the
greatness of hallmark and younger and
more and younger and more and also um
Bride Wars the brother is and I you know
I feel like with Emily at Hallmark in a
second but I feel like with all of these
hallmark movies it's clear good and he a
good guy bad guy corporate farm right
but this was the lines were more blurred
and like the corporate guy wasn't such a
bad guy right so I found it to be very
interesting just I will say I was RDH it
once because they mentioned Christmas
caroling twice and the human sing did
not sing well but they they did use one
of her album Christmas in the city one
of those covers from her new Christmas
album in the promo they did so that was
that was enjoyable and I highly
recommend the flick of your Christmas
movie Stan well I'm sure we have a lot
to discuss we have Hallmark and the
bigotry we have what else we have
Alex combo baby daddy and okay yeah and
we have some other things but we have
SNL abortion yeah that's okay EMT Dee's
birthday we've got it oh yes did his
birthday be I'm saying Kim in the same
room we got it was crazy that is crazy
so was the factor I can by the way I
think Beyonce was actually the snatcher
oh you think so your dress yes I did
like that's just like the level of
glamour you need to bring to P Diddy's
fiftieth birthday like and I know that's
not Kim styled she's really
understanding now when it's like soft
glamour
oh I thought Kim but Beyonce's dress was
it like that's what you wear like I
thought
camless a perfect dream I've never liked
honestly this is the best she's she's
always been looking incredible but like
she took my breath away
she was breathtaking for sure but I
think Beyonce snatch it mm-hmm I'm glad
you feel that way um we'll get should we
I think we should get right in because
we're just let me just cover it in after
just a few quick announcements I just
want to thank everyone who turned the
stoves with me like the stones were
fully turned anyway bring a stone for
you to sign no but you think you're
weird I would say maybe maybe once every
meet and greet someone asked me to sign
something like they bring a Sharpie
whether it's like sign their merch and
by the way like I will never actually be
famous because they don't know how to
braid my own name like it's so hard and
at Turning Stone I would say like half
the people that mean creep on things for
me to sign and nobody brought a stone
that's crazy
I know maybe it's because they were told
that they would be stones provided yeah
oh and the men you just like I just want
to say like it was such a great crowd
interning so and it's not what I thought
it was gonna be like it was first of all
I cannot believe we haven't like taken a
trip to Turning Stone it's beautiful
like the casino like you know it's
killing me you'd like to go home and not
just like sit there and gamble um such a
great crowd really want to thank
everyone for coming turning those stones
there are only seven shows left on the
dirty jeans tour and four of them are in
our own backyard so like I'm a trip to
Chicago this week can't wait to see you
all take the veil ball girl done job
back home I'm pretty sure all three see
all three shows are sold out but there
might be a rogue ticket left it ain't
all about girls no job home then I'm
putting up Kansas City in January which
will be exciting I've never been to
Missouri tickets available Carlow job
huh then my other shows cities in
Missouri by the way it's the most
confusing thing ever also Oklahoma City
in Kansas I think No
yeah there is there's that's crazy well
it's confusing and then like the other
shows our Englewood New Jersey Atlantic
City New Jersey vegan like all here
that's so exciting it's so exciting I
just don't know like what I'm gonna do
after the tour like I just I don't know
what I'm gonna do me
oh we have some plans by the way is it a
store is it a story that world-renowned
travel blogger TPG got engaged no it was
not a story it's worth a brief mention
on the choice he's posting premium
content on his interim they got a drone
for the announcement like it was super
premium I'm not gonna lie I'm so I'm not
just like I didn't know last week and it
was like killing me like I have been I
just want to say like I have been such a
good to see her keeper
like he told me that and like that's
like such big news like I didn't tell
anyone except for you guys but like he
said I could tell you guys he didn't
actually like say it formally but like
there was something like an unspoken if
you tell one sister like you know all
the sisters will know but the sisters
are a steel trap it's it's a bond yeah I
could say and I'm just feeling really
proud of myself and I'm very excited for
them and I'm also really excited for
myself because he BG throws a great like
trip and he there was a great party so
it's like where we going about sûreté
you know where do you think you're gonna
go I mention Vegas and he was like so
into the idea and I'm like really just
trying like push him play charter jet
but he's actually like since I met him
really been raving about how like
amazing of a city Montreal is and how if
he ever got married like he would do his
bachelor party there because there's
tons of casinos he loves to gamble and
he says he really he does say it's like
the Rome of North America I don't know
actually I've heard great things
ya know so he doesn't do that and like
while I'm down to you know take an
international like Vegas is much more my
speed then I took a trip to Vegas this
time last year with gbg and it was one
of the most fun switch it up like you've
done Mia Smith TPG maybe Montreal no but
it was like it was so fun like I need to
recreate the magic of that trip you know
mm-hmm
so we'll see whatever you know but it's
up to the bride and groom's uh I'm so
happy for them me too the engagement was
so sweet and all the content like the
snorkeling and the sharks and the
Dolphins and the good luck lingo I now
just iced and know but it's like you get
married and I mean you get engaged in
the Maldives like where do you go from
there yeah then I think I think it's
like the opposite right you do like
really small like intimate yeah because
you can't go any bigger than the
Maldives so true well congrats bride and
we love you a more sabi for you we do
love you and we are so happy for you and
we'd be remissed gonna transition right
here because they know you have seven
more shows and I feel like sometimes
with these shows like people don't know
what to wear but do I wear for the show
totally but by the way more and more
people like I would say now at the last
show like 90 percent of people were
wearing merch of course and the other
10% of you had to shop morning to us
calm where we have the cutest holiday
and every night the bookings what are
suppose yeah I mean today's like our
last show of the year it's the four days
of toast myths but it's not today it's
not the last show of the year this week
this week is the last week of the year
and it's the four days of toast myths I
plan on wearing
toasty how they merge in everyday life
this week also if you're gonna be
missing us for the next two weeks all of
our we haven't really seen any page
run-up so this month because we're not
here for the last week so January
so we're gonna keep you guys
summer oh my god I can't sleek we're
gonna keep you guys you know engage in
our content for the second half of
December so make sure you're following
us the morning chest patreon patron comm
slash morning shows if you're feeling
RDH that we're going away we will still
be with you we are always with you let
me $7.99 per month for five uh premium
episodes and honestly it's a bargain
yeah and then you get all the past
episodes and it's incredible um so yes
I'm wearing the Christmas sweater it
says let's get toasted I'm wearing a
size extra large and I'm wearing biker
shorts underneath because they don't
need to be like flashing anyone my
coochie oh my god also I said something
on my tour and for Turning Stone like
did something to me where I made the
most disgusting joke like I couldn't
believe that came out of my mouth and so
are you gonna say it again or you know
I'm not gonna say good but I utilize the
words and you know it was so disgusting
okay and this is our Hanukkah sweater
yes we're an inclusive brand I won like
hallmark of course um I love the blue of
this sweater I also love that our ugly
Christmas sweaters aren't actually like
having it and they're just sweaters that
you can wear with I have boots and make
you write those knits like are cute for
a moment but not for life yeah like and
I fully intend to wear these sweaters
year-round so head to shop morning to
calm these two sweaters are still
available if you didn't get your toasty
Lights pre-order sweater your RDH and
that's on you know actually you have 17
more minutes if you we we made those
Christmas toasty sweaters available for
pre-order so you can get one in January
if you want one um until 11 a.m. so
that's literally 17 more minutes if
you're listening to this as a podcast
you missed it but if you're watching us
live had to shop morning shows calm also
what we have stockings if you order now
you will get the stockings for Christmas
so you'll owe everything for Christmas
except for toasty lights everything
lights up right now you'll get it in the
next few days so these are the toaster
stockings they're pink they're so cute
on the stream yeah I love these they're
so premium yeah I wish Adam mantel and
like you know Christ in my soul and I
would have just bought one uh
about what one of these well you have
one look at what yeah but it like you
think these aren't this is something
that I feel like everyone needs a
talking its cultural Christmas yes but
like for example I couldn't get
ornaments because I couldn't have a tree
yeah and then that's where like I was
already each but I'm living for the
content no but that's like our cross
Samara just by their being Jewish jeans
like there's so many benefits to being a
part of the Jewish tribe but don't get
me wrong I love it
but like the one the one situation where
I'm like sitting out feeling left out
feeling RDH is sexy people's like
stunning Christmas trees no I know and I
feel like people are getting to a place
where they think that Christmas trees
like aren't a religious
staying anymore and it's like no no like
I love the Christmas holiday more than
anyone but I don't think it's acceptable
I think it's weird I think it's weird
I'm like you know really getting close
to the point where like I want to get
one I would never I dunno I do think
it's weird for for non-jewish people and
I'm sure some people very great for a
Jewish for Jewish people to have a
Christmas tree I know some people who do
I think it's weird and I'm jealous
so yeah I'm mostly just jealous but
that's just like a line that I won't
cross I know
because then it's just like it's mayhem
and a Christ Chris Christmas is the day
Christ was born like it's still a deeply
religious holiday exactly it's very sad
for us but but get your Hanukkah sweater
get your Hanukkah sweater challah french
toast airs what's good so that we can
all participate in this wonderful
holiday yeah some of us more than others
without further ado it is time for the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and that's true
for sure
but I would be I wouldn't be doing my
job honestly if I didn't let everyone
know that today's episode is brought to
you by one of our newer sponsors that
took the toaster world by storm last
week the serial school oh um because if
you just like me who like literally when
she was on vacation all she does is eat
sugary cereals because like she thinks
she's 12 years old but she's not she's a
full-blown 25 woman year old woman who
like me to get her life together that's
just because I'm obsessed with cereal I
was as a child like we were not allowed
to have sugary cereals and that really
made me rth like we were like succumb to
like Cheerios and stuff but now as an
adult like I can do whatever I want
except that I can because I can need to
stay healthy but you remember what it
used to feel like picking out your
favorite sugary cereal before we were
all told to avoid extra carbs most
sugary cereals are bland dry and get
soggy way too fast I can attest to that
seeing as how we were grown up on bland
shooting on sugary cereals and the
cereal milk doesn't taste good either
with blends
cereals that was always the best part
that is all changing now thanks to the
cereal school they let you eat like a
kid again with delicious low-carb
sugar-free a high-protein cereal it's
all the flavors you love to cinnamon bun
fruity cocoa peanut butter and more to
come they're low carb no guilt just for
fun delicious snacks that won't blow
your macros it was founded in early 2019
by business and life partners Helen and
Dylan that is so cute cereal school
makes healthy snacking fun convenient
and most importantly delicious you do so
much for everyone else make sure to
reward yourself with a guilt-free snack
a day or night you
choose from flavors like cocoa cinnamon
bun or peanut butter they have no gluten
no grain lactose soy or sugar and it has
16 grams of protein per serving it's
naturally sweetened with zero glycemic a
monk fruit no artificial sweeteners or
sugar substitutes so the reason why the
cereal school is so cute and why I
really loved it and my favorite flavor
is the peanut butter is because you can
eat it like a chip like a snack it's
like a bag or I just found out you can
use the bag it's like a little bowl and
pour a little milk in it or almond milk
whatever you like so cute so fun and I
just love eating cereal like I think
cereal I do like I'm never grown out of
cereal and I think it's just like the
best snack ever but it's also like
terrible for you they come into anymore
single serve packaging so you can mix
and match flavors to create your perfect
variety pack they're perfectly portioned
so there's no guesswork or tedious
measuring it's great for kids or
on-the-go snacking there are only a
hundred calories for bag so it's even
keto season approved the cereal school
is the fastest growing low carb cereal
in the world there's over 5,000
five-star reviews online and they've
been featured in articles like Forbes
box women's health and more the cereal
school is a healthy and delicious snack
that fits perfectly with any nutritional
needs plus our listeners can get five
dollars off and free shipping when you
go to the cereal school.com slash tous
the cereal school is so confident that
they offer a risk-free satisfaction
guarantee on all orders so the only way
to get five dollars off and the free
shipping is to go to the cereal
school.com slash toast that's th e CER
ei L SCH ool comm slash toast the cereal
school enjoys cereal like a kid again
sign-on eat cereal love it okay well
speaking of Christmas hallmark is the
center of controversy which is usually
never the case but Hallmark Channel has
vowed to reinstate same-sex wedding ads
and apologizes for their wrong decision
okay so we woke up this morning to some
good news because it was a tumultuous
weekend for home marquees because at the
behest of a group called 1 million moms
what sorry they should change the name
to 1 million loser imams hallmark pulled
a commercial for Zola that featured was
a Zola yes oh my god that featured a
same-sex marriage and they apologized to
the 1 Million Moms and then everyone
else in the world took umbrage with that
decision and now Hallmark Channel is
walking back its decision to pull
multiple commercials featuring same-sex
couples
kissing out their weddings quote the
crown media team has been agonizing over
this decision as we've seen the hurt it
has unintentionally caused said simply
they believe this was the wrong decision
said Mike Perry president and CEO of
Hallmark cards Inc in a statement
obtained by people on Sunday quote our
mission is rooted in helping all people
connect celebrate traditions and be
inspired to capture meaningful moments
in their lives
anything that detracts from this purpose
is not who we are we were truly sorry
for the hurt and disappointment this has
caused the statement continued yes this
is incredibly losery and I'm all for
people understanding their mistakes
taking a step back I'm totally here for
it
but like for the two days that like they
pulled this thing and like everyone was
making fun of them like that was so
losery and like this group 1 million
moms like no sis like this is not the
battle you want to like die on no and
I'm so glad that hallmark did the right
thing this morning because it was it was
upsetting as a hallmark II that they
would do that it's just losery like I
could never imagine like caring that
much about a commercial do you know what
I mean like that you would start a group
to get it taken down right in such a
benign commercial totally celebrating
love like my god [ __ ] off like the lose
at low level of loser eNOS here is that
of Maria Menounos getting married on New
Year's Eve I would say it's reached
astronomical Maria Menounos levels may
be even surpassed right but now 1
million moms are gonna be furious yeah
and their 1 million kids are like mom
just relax can you drive me to school
thank you so much a Hallmark Channel in
peace it's so stupid like that's just
what gets like so frustrating about
these types of situations is that like
the Hallmark Channel like they're just
trying to make make dumb movies for like
people to watch during the holidays like
it's not that serious like so now it's
just like you're 1 Million Moms are
making into like a whole big coffered
yah for like just leave the movies alone
ok like leave the commercials alone just
record it on TV are anyway and just skip
it if you don't like it like just shut
the [ __ ] up yeah just shut everyone
getting their panties in a twist about
things that have nothing to do with them
but you're not gay shut up right also I
just think it's it's ridiculous like
Hallmark even like going back and forth
just because of what people are saying
they don't like this they don't like
that like oh we're gonna start a
petition ok we're canceling this
commercial like do what you think is
right I'm gonna get go like have the
courage of your convictions to pin like
no I'm sorry people don't like this oh
okay let's drop this person like over
here it's a stupid commercial nobody can
watch this pourcel's anymore and it's
just like I just can't tell with people
who like like if you're a gay like shut
the [ __ ] up like why n even if you
like why does this bother you like I
just don't understand like being
bothered by commercial I will never get
to the level like where I'm not to sell
but like I'm too self-absorbed to ever
give a [ __ ] about a commercial so the
pellets have didn't bother me I have GDR
and I usually would skip it I probably
would have never seen it if it weren't
for one Million Moms also I don't have a
peloton so this honestly this commercial
doesn't apply to me honestly I saw the
commercial maybe ten times before the
conch of the peloton continued yes and
on TV like regular yeah regular and then
when they heard there was a controversy
about it I was just like what did I miss
world that is so funny did you see e
news it like a whole expose like get you
know the woman behind the peloton
commercial I'm fine I'm fine not now
okay I love it anyways thank you
homework you're doing the right thing
here everyone else who has a problem
with this like sit down grab food that's
not weird grab a spoon and just like
move on with your life because it's a
beautiful commercial it's a celebration
of love and there's absolutely nothing
wrong with that absolutely nothing like
literally there's never been anything
less wrong with the commercial stop it
seriously sit down thank you um okay are
you ready for our next story because
it's like the craziest story CSV
Keystone Alex composted caras and
girlfriend ELISA Salerno are expecting
their first child which as we all know
now is the news of the day she is
pregnant there were some rumors about it
and now it is confirmed but ahead of
gender reveal yesterday at his house on
the public beach to me the crazier news
is news that's actually making waves on
the morning toast Instagram because
Juliet Porter commented on our Instagram
post about it saying weird how he
cheated on her with me several months
ago but ok oh my god wait I totally
misread that I thought she said weird
how he cheated on me with her weird how
he cheated on her with me on it so Julia
that was hooked up recently why does she
do that why did she hook up with Alex I
have no [ __ ] clue oh my god so wait
so we that's so crazy
yeah oh my god I totally misread her
caption I mean her comment and then I
realized the news that was breaking in
that comment she is so funny honestly
like I can't believe that like this is
where we're at now you know that's like
alex has they're having a child like is
he gonna be on the show still no and if
he gonna still [ __ ] around with Juliet
like for me it seems like you're having
a child okay like your life is you're
settling down and you're gonna make your
bed and lay in it wait all this is over
yeah and make it work with this girl but
like is he still gonna be like in the
fuck-boy arena yeah I feel like
technically he could be and it's like
he's
never ever done the right thing he's too
young honestly to be graduated from [ __ ]
boy like if you're that young and you're
a [ __ ] boy and you kind of graduate out
of it like you're at a level of maturity
that like most people will never achieve
in their life and I just I don't think
alex is that mature right but sometimes
I mean Parenthood fatherhood that can
change people truly overnight I know but
he has like comes from very wealthy
parents who like do whatever they want
for him and like give him everything
he's never had to like work hard for
anything so it's like this baby's gonna
be taken care of by someone you know you
probably not Alex oh you know what let
me give them a benefit that oh yes mate
doesn't mean I take the back let me give
him the benefit of the doubt
like babies change people babies change
people right so like maybe he's just
like in a setup shop with Elissa and
their family by the way totally random
tangent I promise well you're back to us
but you just see that incredibly cute
gay couple that got engaged at the shits
Creek like they mimicked dan levy and
whatsoever thing Patrick yeah yeah the
agreement it was so cute what a cute
place to get engaged like if that's like
a meaningful thing in your relationship
very very sweet yes sorry okay no back
to Alex combo um they had a
gender-reveal party last night they're
having a girl
they did it with like a play and like
they're so extra I can't I'm still
unclear like where all their money comes
from and it's like giving me Chris Lee
dives uh no I think he's on a lot of
Coast dad's got a lot of commercials
they're like lawyers for like ambulance
what's it anyone chasers yeah what is
there's company Noah Barnes yeah they're
the Saline of Barnes of Wow I wonder to
see know him Barnes a rich wonder when
we reported that Selena on Barnes broke
up broke up because Barnes his daughter
wanted to work at the firm and Selena
said no oh I just thought they were like
getting too big for their britches no no
it was all about the daughter like
wanting to work at firm interesting I
didn't see that part okay I feel bad for
people who don't live in New York and
have never seen the Cellino and Barnes
commercial but wherever they're from
they have their own version of Selena on
Barnes and it could be the compost
acorus that's true well if you want to
know what goes a little something like
this
Selena and injury attorney
don't wait call late it's pretty good
stuff in our there's like a sexy little
blonde girl on the commercials I see her
she's not weight she's a little
paralegal colony yeah I'm not waiting
for sure well congratulations to the new
mom and dad this is just gonna throw a
wrench in the key and like I've said
before anything can happen in siesta key
and this is just proof of that I
actually spoke to Juliet and Chloe last
night it was right after they found out
that they were having a girl and I guess
I get really like they I guess they've
known that she was pregnant for a while
but something about a gender-reveal like
makes things really real that they like
we're dumbfounded they just like
couldn't get over it I was like Juliet
like that could have been you
right she was like I know my girl I
wonder how she feels like if she's our
dhf she's glad I think she's I think the
way that we've all seen Alex and like
the dangers of their relationship and
like what why it's so problematic I
think now she's actually seeing seeing
like what he's going through now like I
just think like she's really I mean I
can't speak for her but I think she's
probably incredibly relieved that it's
not her because it very well could have
been and I don't think these two planned
on having a child like no but like now
he's with her forever and isn't no he's
not no but like they'll be in each other
they'll be linked forever but just
because they're having a child together
doesn't mean like they're on there
they're linked forever they're linked
forever which is great but also not
great because if you watch a marriage
story she's like she says something that
like I don't know what it's like to be
divorced like I totally like can imagine
she's like I can't believe cuz they have
a kid together she goes I can't believe
I have to know you forever so you can't
just break up with someone and like no
no they have a kid like the custody like
[ __ ] I can't leave have to you know you
forever and then he goes I hope you
[ __ ] die he's like I literally dream
about you like getting hit by car
because I [ __ ] hate I saw that one
clip that was so sad that was like
really shook were they like so do they
don't tell me but do they wind up
getting divorced do you want to know or
not no but like that's part of it right
no like they get to force the whole time
there's never any reconciliation some of
the commercials it seems like they're on
the fence like I never for one second
thought that they were gonna and you
just don't really know whose side you
take because in the marriage it's like
Adam drivers such a dick so controlling
like it's all about him and his stupid
[ __ ] theater group but during the
divorce like Scarlett Johansson like is
being petty as [ __ ] oh you know was in
it Laura Dern she plays harlot
Johansson's like
cool la setting cool fashionable chic
divorce lawyer she's like the best of
the best
she's so funny and they become like good
friends I loved her I thought she was
the best part of the movie like she
should be nominated for an Oscar because
you can't read her like the home of
you're like is she just like a divorce
lawyer who's telling him everything you
want to hear just as she can take your
money you're like is she actually a good
friend to Scarlett ransom then end up
being really good friends like it's she
was she was excellent I totally forgot I
wanted to mention that she was excellent
okay yeah that's exciting
are you ready for our next story which
is some sad news no Chuy Bravo
Chelsea Lately sidekick it has passed
away at the age of 63 so sad so sad
so Emily Lee how's Chelsea said anything
yes she posted to her Instagram like the
sweetest note she said I'm glad they're
still on good terms she said I loved
this nugget in a big way and I took
great pleasure and how many people loved
him as much as I did and do Chuy Bravo
gave us so much laughter and I'll never
forget the sound of his laughter coming
from his office into mine or his quote
business calls with his quote business
manager or his shoe rack with all of his
children size shoes I'll never forget
him coming to Chris with it coming to
Christmas with my family one year in the
Florida Keys and when my niece who was
five or six at the time saw him she ran
in the other direction directions she
was scared my sister and I were
mortified and we were apologizing to
Chuy he told us quote it's okay lots of
little kids get scared when they see the
big kids coming their way
ha ha ha oh my god I really like to just
got chills I was so so cute and so sad
oh my god oh my god I remember him part
of our upgrade totally we watched Akshay
Chelsea Lately a lot I used to really
like Chelsea hem I used to read her
books um this is so sad like I literally
just got teary-eyed that was like such a
sweet tribute such a sweet tribute he's
so cute did what did he die according to
reports um the Mexican American actor
died suddenly after being hospitalized
with stomach pains while visiting family
in Mexico oh that is so sad Alissa's he
was with his family I guess yeah that is
so sad oh my god I like forgot about him
he was oh gee like yeah he was so
[ __ ] funny
yeah I know what he had a great life he
brought so many people so much laughs he
really made him a star yeah like so many
people were like a fact you know I found
out about it was on Heather McDonald
Instagram because I totally forgot that
she used to be on Chelsea Lately
yep so sad so so sad but he has a
wonderful legacy he does he really
contributed to so many people it's just
positive like experiences by the way
he's reminding me of Kourtney Kardashian
like being on the phone with his
business manager getting seven deals I'm
so excited to talk about Kardashian me
too but you know what Kourtney
Kardashian she'd cease nervous to bring
code get herself some business cards
maybe then she'd actually have a
business that she was [ __ ] passionate
about angry and she wouldn't be such a
[ __ ] lunatic but what would be the
best way for her to go about using this
different hmm I don't know here's how
sarah code that she could use for
business owners or people who produce
their own podcasts like us or losers
like Kourtney Kardashian who have no
real passions being plugged in and
prepared when an opportunity comes as
crucial those moments happen all the
time they're happening now and having a
business card that shows how
professional you are in your pocket
ready to hand out is the first step to
making something happen your next big
opportunity is coming right now and
we're here to help you own the now with
free shipping on any business card in
any quantity choose whatever style
finish shape or paper you like and get
free shipping and because you can pick
the colors fonts designs and images it
means you can create something as unique
and compelling as your business here's
how you get started on your business
card plug your information and logo into
hundreds of fresh designs tailored to
your type of company or upload your own
original layout pick the paper stock
style and quantity that's right for you
you can even upgrade to a unique touch
like rounded corners order and receive
your cards with free economy shipping
and if you needed any more reason to
choose vistaprint you can feel good
knowing that mr. print uses only
carefully selected inks and responsibly
sourced paper stocks your satisfaction
is 100% guaranteed or your money back
they'll make it they'll make it right
mr. print wants you to be able to own
the now in any situation which is why
our listeners will get free shipping on
all business cards any style any
quantity just go to vistaprint.com enter
the promo code toast for free for free
shipping on all business cards any style
any quantity it's a limited time offer
though so make sure you're owning them
now at Mista print.com promo code toast
that will automatically apply free
shipping for your order sign on and get
your [ __ ] together because I've got my
attorney on the line and we're
negotiating seven business deals right
now yeah this supreme is like a great
first step in getting your [ __ ] together
there's so much that you can do on there
that will make you feel like a business
person that you have your life together
every time I had said that my business
card I'll it ought to be like Claudia
joy attorney at law we should also have
the code on the back of our business
cards that you like my card get your own
mr. print comm code toast love it sign
on get your [ __ ] together next story
inside Diddy's a lists 50th birthday
bash quote it was like a superstar
Convention says source do you ever like
have FOMO from things like you would
obviously never be invited to but like
you just have FOMO because like you
think you should be there no cuz I just
know I would have a blast yeah yeah that
was one of those one of those times and
I feel like a lot of like celebrity
gatherings like appear to be fun but
aren't actually fun but I know that for
sure like Diddy's parties are fun yes
the biggest names in entertainment came
out to celebrate Sean Diddy Combs his
50th birthday having been in the
industry for decades it's no surprise
that the guest list was packed with
countless celebs including jay-z and
Beyonce Naomi Campbell cardi B and
husband offset as well as Pharrell uh
sure leo
Lil Kim mary j blige and of course Kim
and Kanye is that Leo as in DiCaprio yes
Scott it weight really quickly did you
see that cardi B gave offset five
hundred thousand dollars in cash for his
birthday present and everyone was like
up in arms about I heard that she had
gotten that who [ __ ] cares why we're
well please tell me what the argument
was for right people were I didn't read
it but I think it has a lot to do with
just like excessiveness and like
wastefulness like you know I don't know
who [ __ ] cares I feel like the cash
is actually like more useful than
another car right and I just again this
is like the 1 Million Moms like why do
you [ __ ] care about what other people
are doing I don't know like anyone who
got actually upset a cardi B like you're
a loser big one
okay back to this party yes are they say
burns talking about the fact of jay-z
Kim Beyonce and Kanye we're already in
the room they were interacting before
this party where did their relationship
stand because it was my understanding
that Kanye and jay-z are not friends and
Beyonce hates Kim that it was my
understanding of that too bad why you
let my understanding is that true yeah
like that's just because Kanye and Jacy
were best friends like before Kim was
married they didn't go to the wedding I
feel like they actually there were a lot
of different emotions
back a few years ago but now it seems
like they're in a place where they're
just not friends anymore because the
wives don't get along and the husbands
aren't getting along so like I don't
think there was active beef but they
just don't hang out anymore that's where
I was at part of me this is just like
what I gather just like as a spectator
part of me thinks that Beyonce just like
thinks she's too good to hang out with
Kim you know cuz beyonce is like a mega
superstar
she's considered scam like a reality of
course I think that's where that started
as when Kanye started dating him and I
think now I don't think honey that
Beyonce like still believes that just
considering what Kim's done has achieved
um but maybe she's just not her type of
girl he and right yeah yeah and also
like the disrespect that was once like
then take shown to Kim like I don't
think you can't forget Kim doesn't
forget no and that's why on her a true
Hollywood story I think part of the
reason why her and Kanye have like such
a strong marriage is because when they
first started dating everyone was like
Kim said she's like you can't date Kim
Kardashian like she's on reality and he
was like I don't care I like her and I
think that's why like they have such
respect for each other because like
everyone told him he couldn't or
shouldn't or chanted date Kim and he was
like I don't care I like her yeah that's
true love but everyone was playing nice
at DD's birthday because I mean of
course what else are they gonna do and
it's just nice to see like it's like
seeing what I imagine you know Marvel
Avengers all your favorite superheroes
in any one room yeah who else is there
Leonardo DiCaprio yep Naomi Campbell
cardi B well uh-oh Khloe and Kylie were
also there they went as each other's
dates oh my god you know I saw them
going all dressed up somewhere but I
didn't realize that's where they were
going but he looked fabulous Beauty
invited just like the best Kardashian's
by the way the best it's crazy yeah like
I have been on a rollercoaster of
emotions with Khloe Kardashian like in
the beginning I think she was everyone's
favorite like she was so relatable so
funny and then like something happened
where like she just kind of like lost
her her rule you know she just lost her
mojo and I think that's what happens
when like you marry someone who like
she's sending every night yeah and who
like puts you in such a bad headspace so
much for her for a while but like this
season she has fully come back as my
number one like I stand so [ __ ] hard
so [ __ ] hard because she stands Kim
that's why I love her if she's just on
the right side of history and I feel as
though she always has been she's a
really good sister she's funny she keeps
it real and I just want the best for her
you know yeah
and that's always a good person to root
for yeah but I also came as - she's like
the peach she's the people's champion
Khloe she really is um wait that's so
cute I didn't know that that's where
they went I was like where are these
[ __ ] coming all dressed up with
nowhere to go right now apparently does
she get stressed up and chiseling her
office okay Kylie left her house like
five times this weekend yes she was wild
oh I went to a charity event where she's
saying rise and shine she wore my coat
oh yeah oh my god that really like took
the world by storm down the coast world
for sure
my life by storm yeah I was floored
because I love that code and I will
never apologize for wearing it even
though some people were like making fun
of me
like I said losers but I didn't like
that's the biggest foundation in the
world oh my god once Kylie has some out
of the guy own anything that Kylie has
which is like so upsetting actually I
own some merch from Kylie see ya you and
some lipsticks yo that's true but like
clothing or bags I know it was just like
the best feeling ever
um no so she Friday night she went to
that event for Justin Bieber she sang
rise and shine she crushed it rushed
then she went out with her friends on a
party bus then the next day she was like
at brunch with Rosalia oh my god yes and
then that may choose that did his
birthday she didn't but she couldn't
make it to Wyoming like come on that was
disappointing
that was disappointing she should be
there 1,000% especially if it's about
getting the show back on the track like
and just about family sister bonding
team building time she should be there
and I understand like me Travis needed
her to be in her world um was it astral
world though I think so yeah
I feel like how's your world just
happened I think they have multiple ones
now I don't know I don't know I don't
know I don't know anyways that was that
was disappointing but we'll get to it
Judy's birthday party looked so
glamorous I really thought Beyonce
looked sensational Kim looked amazing
everyone I love a black-tie party I love
when people show up in that picture of
jay-z and Kanye and Pharrell they're all
wearing like tuxedos I love a fancy
five-star moment love it post Malone was
there Kris Jenner was there so I'm
assuming Cory was there by the way so if
I ever want to ship those two like after
every episode Cory just like [ __ ]
standing Chris and just being supportive
with her dumb [ __ ] ideas you know a
hundred percent it was just a great
night away at the musical pop culture
was everyone there except Kourtney and
Kendall got it well Kendall works so I'm
sure that's why she wasn't there right
Kourtney I'm sure the kids nicely so I
don't know I don't know no but she had
to say home could be a mom mom card okay
they didn't I know story Scarlett
Johansson calls Colin Jost quote the
love of my life on SNL you guys you guys
you guys I just like I'm not okay I've
been feeling a different type of way
about Colin Jost ever since I saw him in
a tight black t-shirt during the ending
credits of like an SNL episode like a
year ago and she's like what I thought I
knew about him and like what I thought
of him is absolutely nothing of what he
actually is I learned
something new about him every day every
Saturday every seeing ScarJo and you
know what I was actually like before it
started I was watching with Zack I was
like I wonder if they're gonna address
it yeah are they gonna do any skits
together they dressed it right out of
the gate it was so funny when she was
like if I do a bad job what they'll fire
my fiance like what are we gonna do
without his paycheck it's like she hires
paid actress in Hollywood [ __ ]
hilarious it was so good they were so
cute they couldn't stop kissing no we're
calling him the love of her life when
like they're engaged right now it was
just so beautiful and then at the end
when he came out and his t-shirt again
and it was that t-shirt is so important
it's this I need to know who makes it
like it fits perfectly hugs every curve
no the two of them I would she like so
hard my mouth John you guys if you
haven't seen that you have to watch the
monologue and the credits and the
credits just to understand that they are
the world's most cutest couple I guess
they've never actually acknowledged the
fact that they're engaged
so like Hollywood was like oh there they
are engaged because like she's worn a
ring and but he's never they've never
really even addressed their relationship
so her just saying I met the love of my
life and calling him her fiance was like
breaking news for the world even though
like obviously we know I couldn't
believe that she addressed him both in
the monologue and then the credits like
they're so [ __ ] cute he's like
low-key kind of short because when he
was standing in Michael che it was a
three of them Michael che was like so
tall and then Scarlett was like pretty
tall then like Colin was only a little
taller than Scarlett okay but again it
doesn't matter who loved his fine love
it's lined and that t-shirt just like
makes you weak in the knees truly so the
episode I thought was so good she did
such a good job she's a great actress
really enjoyed so many sketches I forget
which ones but I was I was truly like
laughing yeah but now it's like annoying
because like I'm like their number one
fan and they don't like have snapchat or
anything like I just don't know what
kind of when I'm ever gonna see content
of them again no but it's good because
now you won't get sick of them like any
other couple that you love then they're
annoying on Instagram and then you hate
them yeah I just like I need more like
that was so cute and they gave us a lot
like I just I was hoping slash expecting
them to just acknowledge it like once
but they gave us a lot to work with
between the kiss in the monologue and in
the credits I was like damn they
couldn't stop kissing it couldn't stop
kissing she's so cute and petite and
tiny and just like cute like she's just
[ __ ] cute and she looked sick in that
red dress in her monologue and then
she'd have like this cute little jump at
the end of the credits and she think the
army I'm gonna be like I just we stand
she just did everything right we have
literally no choice in this world we
have absolutely no choice because united
we stand which is so crazy because I
didn't really feel strongly about her
one way or the other before this
transformative episode yeah and you know
what's also kind of weird about her it's
like she's like low-key controversial so
high she keeps like taking acting roles
that like belong to other people know
one like I think she's like defending
Woody Allen and she's like oh yeah doubt
about that but honestly like I'm blinded
by the love I'm sorry I just don't care
and also the opening monologue was just
good and funny but they dressed Pete
Davidson never showing I am I am when he
says to quell like you can take some
time off when you've been here this he
knew he's ready you can take some time
off when you've been here this long like
know Keenan like literally has a bad
problem for putting the show on his back
to the last 10 years
oh sorry the best part of the entire
episode was Kate McKinnon in the opening
credits being gratitude Berg also I
didn't realize it was pronounced to
burger and I mean either oh my god the
shears just like her it's crazy how Kate
McKinnon can look just like Hillary
Clinton and also Greta tuna burger no I
guess Greta and Hillary Clinton are too
alike she looks just like her who is the
funny [ __ ] ever honestly he was such a
good episode it was great i any murphy
next week right yes
and Liz oh oh sorry I need to talk about
Niall Horan's do I was you had no choice
I was shook first of all he's so cute
with brown hair love the brown hair he
should sit with around here second of
all I feel like he really wanted to use
it as a moment to be like I'm more than
just a boy bander and I'm like I know
I'm not the most successful one
Directioner but I'm not at least I think
I actually might be this second mostly
that's all I actually think I might be
tied for first like Marisa I knew both
songs and their father he could show
maturity I'll play like he is his music
is just like pop gold like it's just
it's great that's so nice to meet you
what's your name is so [ __ ] good his
voice superb loved him on the guitar
like loved a multi-talented artist like
I just stand so hard and then when he
was in the sketch in the hot tub Oh
hilarious and he's just like sitting
next is Carla Johansson I'm like this is
great I would say in a
so if it wasn't so in love with her and
colin jost like they actually might make
a couple no it was really really great I
feel like we sit through a lot of bad
episodes of us and I was just to get
just to ones like that yeah and I'm
actually really excited for anymore
pantry lies Lissa was the musical gas
like wow supreme supreme um I'm like
it's so crazy a waste like sit on the
show and make fun of SNL about how like
it really wasn't funny because for a
while they like weren't doing a good job
yeah I like taking the temperature I'm
like cultural zeitgeist and just like
they were just like kind of out of touch
and like not really commenting on things
we wanted them to comment on I know and
I feel like most of the time they still
do that but when they get it right it's
very right yeah and it was so I think
Weekend Update is like one of the
funniest sketches now maybe I only think
that because I'm in love with Colin Jost
right and like I wouldn't hate Scarlett
Johansson like for marrying like my
husband like if I wasn't so happy for
them that's so crazy
also it also depends on who they bring
out as like the guest yes and bode hang
was so fun so funny and baby Yoda was
was so funny oh my god was so funny when
he first started talking like baby Yoda
and he started talking like an animal
and you're like oh that's what video -
sounds like oh so funny I thought it was
great I thought it was excellent
yeah good stuff check it out if you
haven't seen it speaking of good stuff
last night was the see season finale
don't say series finale of Keeping Up
with the Kardashians we are going to
recap brought to you by one of our
favorite brands here noon news a habit
changing solution that helps users learn
to develop a new relationship with food
through personalized courses it is based
in psychology Noom teaches you why you
do the things you do and arms you with
the tools to break the bad habits and
replace them with better ones
they say it's called cognitive
behavioral approach but honestly we just
say it works new is not a diet you guys
it is a healthy and easy to stick to way
of life they don't consider any food
good bad or off-limits in new they teach
you moderation and that can be used in
conjunction with many pre-existing
popular diets if you want Noom I have I
have noon I actually have said the story
a million times but I feel like it's
really important cuz I went to the
doctor and she was like tell me how like
I need to stop eating and I'm like how
doctor and she was like geez any calorie
counting or like diet tracking apps and
I'm like obviously not and she's like
well I recommend Noom I'm like wait do
you use new Beckham flushed shows it was
actually just so crazy for like a
medical professional to recommend
something like we talked about on the
toast that a lot of toasters have had
success
and I've had success with it chip so
it's nice to know that it's like ask
your doctor and she'll say it's good
Noom has one of the most the biggest and
most accurate food databases available
and they let you track your meal habits
they let you visualize portion size and
see the calorie density at a glance
we're all strapped for time
NUMA asks you to commit to 10 minutes a
day for yourself it's not that hard but
if you're you're human and if you go off
track there's no shaming from new it's
just tips to help you get back on track
tomorrow because we know you're human
and you know people make mistakes
you could also chat with your goal
specialist and Noom community to get and
give help to people going through the
same exact thing you don't have to
change it all in one day small steps
make big progress sign up for your trial
today at noon calm / toast that's n o om
dot-com / toast what do you have to lose
visit noon calm / toast to start your
trial today that's Noom calm / toast the
last weight-loss program you'll ever
need sign-on feelin easy
so the Kardashians took a trip to
Wyoming in an effort to team build Kris
Jenner was at the helm of the trip
because Kourtney is fighting with pretty
much everyone and this just like and I
got what Chris was saying it didn't seem
fake to me I feel like with family it's
like you fight of course and it's
everything goes back to to normal but
some fights and like sometimes you go
through time periods where like you're
afraid to actually might have like long
term effects on your family and I
totally like got the vibe that that was
what Chris was worried about like as
much as the activity seems stupid like
that [ __ ] does help ya like a ring
stupid ropes coins wasn't helping in the
situation but I just thought I'm gonna
say something controversial but I felt
that the commercials for the episode
were actually much better than the
actual episode I felt like it was
lacking also they went to my Oh Megan
was so weird like I thought they live
there and they're staying in a hotel
Courtney's saying she's never been there
before
I thought she Kanye did his album
listening party their haven't they all
been there don't they have houses
they're like oh Kanye has like a 300
acre ranch like yeah they're staying at
a hotel so I got the impression that Kim
and Kanye do have a place there but they
might not have wanted to film I feel
like it's like a special sacred place no
I understand but he was just like
Wyoming is literally their second home
and they were just acting like they were
going to this place for the first time
yeah well no Kim wasn't acting like that
Kourtney was yeah but like she's in the
music videos like oh yeah you know it
was filmed that
I'm listening party like I just it felt
like I don't know it was confusing I it
was confusing
um and the cattle ranch thing it's it
was funny to watch but by the way great
commercial for Miami I've never wanted
to go more I know I'm actually planning
a trip are you for a I'm gonna permit me
my friends if you want to come sure the
words such great things about Wyoming
and I really want to see it um so what I
like the idea of the term except for the
fact that they were trying to like bring
everyone together and it just wasn't
working and it was forced it was getting
like a little stupid I was really really
disappointed that KY late income because
first of all it's indicative of the
entire problem that they came to Wyoming
to fix it's like nobody takes this
seriously and like everyone has
priorities and I get that but like this
show is our mothership like and for her
just not to show up it's like and I get
that she's not a full-time cast member
and we spoke about last week how I think
that's problematic it was disappointing
and I get why Kendall was upset to like
handle literally is one of the hardest
working women in the family yeah she
flew all the way from London and like
Kylie gonna get on a private plane for
two hours
I completely agree brought stormy
because Kourtney randomly brought her
kids even though nobody else said like
come on yeah no it wouldn't have been
such a big deal and I feel as though I
love Kylie like we said man at the altar
but she doesn't have any respect for the
show that really gave her and everyone
else the platform to make a billion
dollar make a billion dollars and it's
like just show up once of course yeah
like I would be I would be just as
annoyed
100 percent because while Kylie is
indirectly get I don't think Kylie gets
paid what Kourtney and Kim and Chloe get
paid for the show so while she's
directly not reaping the same amount of
benefits she's really being more because
she was a sixteen-year-old who people
really gave a [ __ ] about because of the
show yeah so it that that wasn't right
to me so just everything was just kind
of off for a while yeah um including the
activities that they were trying to do
like a cattle drive I don't know how
that helps it was funny because Kourtney
was I had LT rich cattle drive I had no
idea oh really no idea and I was
wondering if they were gonna mention it
oh my god that is so funny so funny
um so that was funny and then the ropes
course you know I love a team building
ropes course me too Nicholson camp toast
we do the same works course at cams
toasting you know we
get really close because of it by the
way I don't know if we announced that we
were going to release tickets after the
holidays so it's overwhelming the the
polls we USC was a land tide we asked
you answered so we responded so tickets
will go on sale and the second half of
January so stay tuned for that Memorial
Day weekend 2020 where we will do a
ropes course much like the car - it's
really fun um but by the way and I but I
know everyone was like making fun of cam
like she was being so dramatic but I get
what she was saying she's like I'm
successful like just because you have a
fear doesn't mean you have to conquer it
and she's like I'm not gonna feel better
if I do like what the [ __ ] am i doing up
here I'm I I'm a success like I don't
need this ropes course to prove that to
me I totally agree but it's funny just
like its Courtney didn't do what I would
have been like really by the way it's so
unfair the way I feel about that it's
also because Courtney doesn't do so many
things so like when you're kidding you
do everything you get to pick and choose
here and there I don't want to do this
but Courtney he doesn't want to do
anything so when she doesn't do another
thing it's like you don't do anything
you know totally and I definitely didn't
understand like why she was like fake
leaving like it can be fun to be
fighting with everyone now and when the
point of the trip is to mend fences and
all the fences need to be mended with
you like I
it's a terrible position to be and no
matter how mature and mature like I
would want to leave to so I didn't fault
her for that and they were definitely
just like so snappy with each other like
everything was a [ __ ] fight so I Jude
commend her for going and staying I
understand why she brought her kids like
her being on a different plane like it's
just I think that's ridiculous for a
two-hour flight that they they'd even
need two planes like when she was like
no one wants to be on a crammed plane
like are you kidding are you kidding me
and and it's true while while I would
say like if Kim and her kids were on and
she wanted her own plane like I would be
like that's totally fine because to me
like they're not equals and I know in a
family everyone supposed to be equal but
it's like even when they dress up as
each other and Courtney was like making
fun like everyone I started all this
like I am the reason why we have a
career like it's true right so it's like
Courtney gets by off the fruits of
everyone else's labor like she doesn't
really work she doesn't care to work but
she enjoys all the benefits of it like
it's I totally get why Courtney I like
Kim and Chloe get so frustrated like cuz
I'm getting frustrated and I'm not even
a member of his family right it's like
you don't get to not work and then have
your own plane right and and by the way
the reason why we're taking this trip is
to fix the fact that you don't work and
you don't care like it was frustrating
yeah and even though that was like super
funny how they all dressed up as each
other
it was really indicative of a lot of
things like the way the way people truly
feel about you comes out when like
they're making fun of you yeah I'm Sol
honestly I like I wouldn't be able to do
it like oh my god that was nothing
Savage I can't believe that was the
thing I brought them together because
when I saw the commercial side of
Kendall making friend of Kylie I was
like you jealous wench like how dare you
actually I thought that was
light-hearted and funny and I didn't
think anything of it I thought what
Courtney said about Kim was the mean
it's like I'm helping people get out of
jail like you [ __ ] jealous [ __ ] no I
like that how can you make fun of that
yeah no it was it was not funny and like
okay this is easy this is easy my
stylist put me in sweatpants like
jealousy losing from her veins I thought
that that was funny it was like I have
seven stylists who put me in leggings
and spice like that hilarious I thought
that the Kris and Chloe were totally
light-hearted like bed babe a buck that
was funny
where's my martini Matthew all really
funny like that's like the type of stuff
you can poke fun at but I thought
Cortney like was just really going in
and bugging me so it was Kim like mom
guard mom car I'm gonna go pretend to be
a mom that was me yeah there really is
definitely really like bad blood between
Kourtney and Kim I think they get under
each other's skin conserve ammo suggests
similar but I think at the end of the
day it's like they because they're fat
like they don't have bad but I feel like
it's even like our family like when two
people are just like going at it it's
like there's never a reason no it's
there's never a real enough issue where
it's like there's bad but it's like oh
you just into each other like right like
they still love each other and like Kim
would take a bullet for right what I
thought was funny was that in an effort
to look like Kourtney Kim looked boring
like there's like I don't know how you
wouldn't really like dress up as
Kourtney Kardashian you know what I mean
well you did but you don't have red hair
you don't I mean like Kim has such a
signature style so does Kris so does
Chloe like I knew exactly so does Kylie
like I knew everyone was gonna be like
honestly Kim dressed up as Courtney she
could have been Kendall too like I dunno
yeah yeah it's true but I thought and
I'm glad it all worked out and that was
the thing that brought them together and
I'm glad that the sisters realized that
doesn't make Courtney happy and it
doesn't make the viewers happy and also
like at the end of the day we love them
because they're our family and the
fighting is funny here and there but
it gives you a pin like I don't want to
see my favorite family fighting yeah and
watching them force Courtney to film is
not fun because we can tell when it's
fake
I do wish though that they had addressed
the fact that they that Courtney is
taking a full step back what they
announced it via E news or whatever like
they should have announced or like put
out I thought they were gonna put up
like a little text screen just like
making a story like come full circle
yeah well to us it now we totally see
Rowe and why she reach that decision and
I think it'll be better for everyone at
sometimes if you love something set it
free and it was ever truly yours it will
return and I think a break would be good
for Courtney I'm the viewers and by the
end I really did feel for her like
that's not a fun position to be in to
feel like everyone's ganging up on you
even though she's just as mean as anyone
else like when it's everyone being mean
to you it's a different feeling than
like you being mean to ever like Kim and
Khloe like sitting there laughing at her
and you know like saying things under
their breaths no no totally I did start
to feel for her too and I do think her
moving on is the right decision but I
need to know like where where everyone
else is gonna start picking up the slack
because right while Courtney was a big
problem it's not the only problem like
Kendall and Kylie coasting on through
becoming the biggest model in the world
and the first self-made billionaire
without having to put in the work on the
show like that's not fair well I feel
like Kendall in like a few seasons ago
was trying to do more and she was
filming with like Jenna and doing
confessional oh yeah already and it must
have not tested well because they were
like they stopped doing it so I do like
the problem with Kendall saying okay
she's available to film but like there's
not much people want to see and just
seeing her on set and she won't share
her dating life right so we're like what
exactly and a show with just Khloe and
Kim and Kris I think we got I think Kris
is a star like I would watch an entire
show I'm Kris I think she's the most
interesting she's hysterical she pokes
fun at herself she likes to drink she
likes to party
I love Kris like I would watch a whole
show on Kris I think Kris needs to
really step up even though like she's a
full-time job like managing 10,000
people I think she needs to step up I
would like to see more Kylie I don't
really need to see more Kendall but I
just need to see other people besides
Khloe and Kim right and like a malika
sure no I mean like you can't put the
show on the friends honestly we need
Stas we do we do just something think
about yes but it doesn't mean like give
us more Jonathan and Malika no oh my god
MJ yeah but you know what like maytee
anymore Sophia they put a lot of content
out like maybe I would I would like less
episodes with more juice you know what I
mean ah I don't know I feel like every
season is like two months long it's not
even that long they're coming back
spring 2020 that's like yeah months away
yeah I don't know I think it's great um
I'm excited to see what they do
yeah they're obviously like in this
rebuilding restructuring phase and I'm
excited to see where it takes it I look
forward to watching it me too and the
other TV oh great houses of Atlanta was
on last night incredibly boring I've
absolutely nothing to share with you I
was like what am I gonna recap to Jackie
except Marlo and Portia like how to
really fund it where they took one of
those bikes out like you know those bike
trolleys we're like there's a man
driving you and like you drink in the
back but you can also pedal well yeah
I'm in Asheville they took one by
themselves in like all wasted and then
went to Genesis like hot dogs and it
just looked like a fun day I don't
really like give a [ __ ] about like the
inner workings of candies like extended
family like she has a stepdaughter and
like kind of Todd's relationship like
it's chill boy like I don't care um Nene
like wasn't in the episode neither was
Eva and Cynthia Bailey just continues to
run off her life around a man and it's
just like so boring to watch like a
successful businesswoman just like all
she cares about is getting engaged chill
okay so she's seeing this guy he was
Mike Hill and her name is Cynthia Bailey
but she's gonna become Cynthia hill when
they get engaged but like even though in
the show they haven't gotten engaged yet
in life they have so she's see Hill
Cynthia Hill so there they had a couple
of hashtag is hashtag Jill it's so
stupid it's so lame like all the women
are in there are engaged yeah
and all she talks about is getting
engaged and like they do get engaged
because in real life we now know that
they are engaged I think at the end of
the season but she just looks so
desperate like another season of her
just like like chasing after a man it's
just like it's so sad
hate to see it happen to a successful
businesswoman hate to see it happen but
I hope that she gets her happy ending
yeah whatever I'm just all 14 Porsche Oh
like I would watch a whole show on
Porsche I love her so much and I just
want happiness for her and if that's
getting back together with her ex even
though he was accused of bestiality like
it's okay because we're together it was
never found it like it was just it was
just allegations from like a blog like
that's insane
yeah no it's like rumors like that don't
just start you know but sometimes they
do do they though I don't know thank you
guys so much for watching the morning
shows make sure to get your holiday
merch order it now before you guys
sweatshirt all the sweatshirt said I
wear a size large I wear them as a dress
even though I am wearing shorts
underneath a size large when I want to
wear it as
Spyder and a size extra-large when I
want to wear it as a dress this is the
Christmas sweater Jackie is wearing the
hanukkah getting lit sweater we have
onesies available we have these
beautiful stockings available we have
obviously the og pop sockets water
bottles all that stuff we have a lot of
stuff that's on sale so if you just want
like pop sockets and other things as
stocking stuffers get the stocking and
the stuffers at shop morning toys comm
there's so much good stuff there and you
will get it in time for the holidays
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning to us the Millennial morning
show where we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to give us a
thumbs up five star view you know the
whole thing subscribe we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found set Spotify iTunes stitcher
public video I already know cashbox all
the apps so wherever you listen to
podcasts at subscribe to us leave a five
star review and maybe a comment about
our beautiful stunning and smart we are
we love you guys so much we hope you
have an amazing day and we'll see you
tomorrow tomorrow hi
[Music]
you
we are back with the hardest-working man
in the music industry someone we have
been dying to talk to you for so long
anti grammars here we are so excited to
have you here we love you we stand so
hard and we by the way I've been like
standing since day one like everybody I
love you so deeply thank you for
everyone's like now on the bandwagon but
like we were here first
you're here first actually Jackie was
like the first person created the
bandwagon and then I got people on yes
that's great no we truly love love love
your music we always have you put on an
album this year oh that just for me like
it's my album of the year and I think
you do dance nabbed in the awards I by
the way I agree the album really did
like there are so many great songs that
we love so much and we'll get into them
but I just think the overall theme of
the album it's like I don't know the
vibe the vibe that I got was like you
were like leading advice for your
children mm and I just thought it was
such a beautiful album like and all the
different stories told him the advice
given like I stand thank you thank you
so much it's shedding I was doing my
makeup when it came out and I was
listening to yours and I actually like
started thinking about like everyone I
love dying and I had to turn off that
song I'm yours is truly like
heart-wrenching what you painting
sometimes you need a song like that yeah
you know yeah we're gonna get you in
your feelings it's been awesome you know
I love that the two of you're so
freaking sweet to me about I see you on
you know it's such an interesting time
we're like I've seen you be so sweet to
me online so it's nice to kind of like
give you a real hug we are number one
stands and so the album has been out now
for Ohio sorry well and what has it been
like you have not stopped working yeah
we've been going hard it's like so cool
to have stuff that really hits people
like in the heart yeah I have been on
tour you've been doing so much process
are you on GMA you do pop-up concerts in
the subway like yeah
of all the things that you do and where
you get to perform wasn't you find to be
the most rewarding like where you get
like that immediate feedback I mean the
show like I do on a tour that's the best
you have all your everything's all set
up for like exactly how you wanted all
the lights like everything you know we
did a meet-and-greet this year that was
crazy cool
where I have this song called wish you
pain so good and so we had the
meet-and-greet was everybody come in we
stand in the circle usually about
between fifty to hundred people and I
just open up the dialogue for tell me
your deepest pain that's ever happened
in your life and what a forced you to
grow into right and it was wild yeah so
for like an hour a day I was hearing
them gnarliest things that can happen to
humans and then they'd say from a place
of strength like but it may it turn me
into this well I wouldn't want to give
back what I like what I turned into it
and how does it make you feel to know
that people when they are going through
things like that a lot of people rely on
music specifically your music because it
is the type of music that can heal and
how does it make you feel to like see
people who have been so directly
impacted by your music it just feels
like like like the most basic correct
yeah it's like oh yes this is totally
where I'm supposed to do right I'm in my
zone I'll play with my purpose this is
really great you know it's all like
don't give up on me like next uh I've
had songs that have done hopefully what
that one does for other people yeah yeah
and that song went like to another level
but it was in a movie right yeah yeah I
was actually trying to Justin Baldoni
yesterday he's in town what what movie
was on fire department yes oh my god
okay
that band that song is so good and like
that movie was so sweet so me and him
were roommates in Los Angeles when we
when I first moved out almost like 10
years ago Wow and and just for the two
of us houses first like major movie that
went into theaters and he called me as
the movie was almost done he's like do
you have anything for it and I sent him
this song and I just written it that
week
and then it's so sweet because the end
credits is his his name comes up as the
director and that's what's so so good
two of us it was really special
yes but then the other thing about this
song is nutso that it had its first life
with the movie mhm and then these kids
are singing this song oh are you saying
this I think you were just on CNN Heroes
Security's [ __ ] children good lord
Oh cute and so talented and I love that
you keep bringing them with you like so
it's it wasn't just like a one-time
thing
so every day I'll open up my phone and
there'll be another school from another
part
world like the full school singing with
like young elementary school kids
singing don't give up on me it's really
sweet and so you just perform with them
at CNN I just gave you the CNN Heroes
what a nervous mmm
really that's crazy but could you court
think to get to do like when you just
like love to sing in your kid yeah yeah
they were all so bubbly and excited and
that's amazing and I'm sure they just
like love you I love them weren't it was
really good well you've been doing this
for a while and I feel like we've gotten
to listen to music of yours through like
different stages of your life and now
you're at like such a good stage in life
where you're having kids and you're
married and do you find it like the
experience of writing music when like
you're now writing directly to like your
wife and kid like yeah you know what I
mean is it different I think it's
awesome I think there's a myth
especially in all entertainment that the
goal is to be like 21 and hot right like
your artist you can sometimes get like
even get lost in the pole of what that
is yeah and then if hopefully you know
as you get older you go oh that's like
cool too yeah anyone's fine I mean those
were fun yeah but there's something so
sweet I just turned 36 when I'm about to
have another little girl dad no you
don't have two girls in my house yeah
and there's a lot of really sweet things
to be to be brought up about life and
tell stories about this time and so this
album was like kind of unabashedly about
that
yeah like a little bit deeper heavier
things that I think are beautiful and
really interesting to chew on yeah I
have my own podcast called the good
parts and I just love a stir I love to
ask people like what do you think
happens when you die what do you think I
think that it's like like so I have my
baby girls coming in April mm-hmm right
now she is in the womb which is like a
kind of it's like in this world but not
really right and then she's growing arms
and legs to use here mm-hmm so I think
we're here this is a womb of sorts yeah
and the next spot is where you like use
your spirituality your kindness your
gratitude your we're like growing yeah
we're growing this way to be used
somewhere else wait like I don't think
this is the point of it all no there's
got anymore
I bet I totally agree yeah
a great way of looking I came to that
conclusion like two years ago where it's
like there's something else because like
people who are like good young people
who die like they're not dead like
they're better no it keeps going there's
something else for them so I love going
into like topics like this and it's
always been fun for me in pop music
which is kind of like famously thin hmm
to try and figure out how in a three and
a half minute song can you still go
somewhere special yeah and you
definitely do that and you I feel like
we have a great podcasting voice as well
Oh I mean we're never soothing very
soothing
do you like a new podcaster I love it
right it's like like talk and talk just
in-house scattered our lives are it's
really nice to just sit with someone
like the both of you and just like air
it out a little bit yeah go nice by the
way I totally agree podcasting is you
know that's revolutionary it is but I
think like it's not a crazy idea it's
just no just talking it for a second you
know how would love to hear your
thoughts because uh Variety magazine put
Conan O'Brien we like can't get over it
but Conan O'Brien on the cover of their
magazine saying you know podcasting is a
new medium and Conan O'Brien is the
pioneer and it's like didn't anyone even
know Conan O'Brien had a podcast how do
you let's do it no he's gonna be the
word pioneer that's [ __ ] right like
that's Joe Rogan yes yeah pioneers not
correct what someone who came in and
he's got like great guests and it's why
why am i blowing up Conan oh yeah I
appreciate your good blow up your own
podcast but the cool parts the good
parts who is your dream guest for your
podcast so I just love anyone who I
think is inspiring and then I like to
ask them I think we're all so afraid to
talk about like anything of depth yeah
right now mm-hm
so especially because everything can be
so soundbite E and that's what's
wonderful about pop podcast yeah but
also like people are afraid to like be
vulnerable and just like talk because
they get many fun of everything like the
internet is slow evil so who would want
to be that but if you have enough time
to create context around it like I'm
saying with Dan Reynolds for imagine
dragons I'm like what do you think I was
when you die he tells me all about what
the Mormon faith believes I'm like he's
a really cool guy he's the coolest Derek
Leslie Odom jr. like I get a lot of
really cool people to come and then I go
like tell me what you actually believe
about like God yeah go that's so amazing
if you only have like five minutes you
go like I don't think so right if you
have an hour that you can go like okay
I'll tell you how I grew up what I was
raised like this is what my thoughts are
on this you know or even like when my
favorite questions is like what's your
most spiritual experience well you gotta
go I would say my most spiritual
experience was going to the Kotel for
the first time yeah like I was really
shook the western wall in Israel oh wow
and I've been like many times now but I
remember the first time I went it was
like very overwhelming and I was like
old enough to understand the importance
and like just like I got really like
emotional I just started crying it's
like it's like oh like you know all the
people who like worked so hard I'm like
it was you're surrounded by so many
people of like different face and it's
just like this piece of wall but like it
means so much to so many people I
remember just being like so impacted by
the fact like everyone around me had
like a different book like someone had a
by but it's not like a Hindu like it was
just really uh earthly you know yeah
that's beautiful question I feel like my
I don't want so I feel like it's wet
like from a movie that I saw a movie
about the Holocaust called um paper
clips have you ever seen it no oh my god
it was like the first time that I said
like it came out when I was like in
middle school or maybe in elementary
school was the first time that I got
understood like the scale of the world
across like as a Jewish person it just
like had me like it understand like the
significance of like being a Jew being
alive in this time period where I'm able
to do that right and it just like made
me feel I don't just I gave me
perspective on the world I supposed to
just like my little eighth like seven
Barbie life you know yeah yeah on the
playground these are my favorite yeah
even after that I'm like okay cool I
love you mine yeah you're right like
seeing I feel like everyone tells press
and they talk about like the same three
things like what your goals who inspires
you
so podcasting is an interesting format
because you get people for 30 minutes or
40 minutes but you never get on the
Today Show you get ten seconds like yeah
it's nice to like break down because I'm
not just gonna sit down and tell you
everything about me like you break down
that wall I'm like you become more
comfortable and that's why we love it
yeah and as a listener to you kind of
figure hanging out and then also for
like a branding perspective like you
having a podcast like
so much chance you know I'd like you a
lot to say you know and you're such an
interesting 9 you have really been
around the block and you've been around
for a while I have another question yes
/ what's the best thing worst thing
about money oh I would say the best
thing about money is like not having to
worry sure you know cuz like that
feeling of not knowing like when your
next paycheck are just like having like
the uncertainty of that like that's a
terrible feeling but the worst part is
like you think what you think about of
money is gonna do for you but then like
versus what it actually does like cuz it
doesn't really do a lot just gives you
guys things but you think it's like once
I get to this benchmark like I will be
happier like I can start to feel a
certain way then you get to that
benchmark it's like damn I feel the same
like I'm still having emptiness well
it's just like everything is relative so
like once you get to that benchmark it's
like now you have bigger needs it's like
the saying like more money more problems
it's like the money creates problems
that you didn't have before so I agree
that the best part is like that you
don't have that anxiety like how many I
know so real um but then you have new
bills no and it's just like and it's
also the perception of money is like
what what you think it is it's never
what it is you know yeah and also the in
society of like am I gonna have this
money forever like oh how do I make sure
to keep this money or like to spend this
money why like it just it creates a new
set of things that you think about yes
love this that's a great question you
have any other teep to our questions
okay so I'm about to have another little
girl okay and with my first girl I would
ask every every girl that I met or even
like just like strangers or I like Coast
the Today Show I asked Jenna Bush she
was next to me I was like tell me one
thing your dad did awesome and one thing
he did like he could do better
oh that's a good question our dad died
when we were young so we only had I was
like 14 yeah it's like we don't have
that much time I would say uh one like
the great thing that he did is that he
had four daughters and he had you know
different interests and I was like he
loved to fish and he always like got us
involved in that like i weirdly like
know how to fish now because of that
where I was like why would I not
efficient yeah it was like me it wasn't
like because we had different interests
we did different things like you have to
come to this and I have to come to add
so the crossover I guess that's just
like any dad having all go
but like growing up in a house of all
girls it's very girly yeah it's very and
you wouldn't expect that we were
spending our weekends waking up at 6:00
a.m. like going fishing
yeah we were yeah you know it's the
worst thing he did was that I was just
gonna say that like really on [ __ ]
below guard and I'm actually really
disappointed in the next time I see you
I'm going to yell at him back leaving us
high and [ __ ] my mom passed I
was 25 and how dare she
dark things say like dead parents close
Oh like we definitely have that for sure
and there's like a and I I think it
makes people uncomfortable when we joke
about it and we're not joking about it
because we're uncomfortable we're doing
about it cuz like that's how you get
through right because we can so you
might not have had that reaction if you
also weren't a part of the figure it out
passed away me my dad and my brother
were like alright we're all gonna just
go see something to pick us up we're
gonna go see up depressing [ __ ] movie
holy [ __ ] the first it's terrible it
starts with the mother dying right off
the top so the three of us are in the
theater and we like go we're watching
and then it just like slowly start to
realize that she's good she's gonna pass
away and then we just art we're all
crying so hard in the theater so
depressing so much so that it became
like funny yeah yeah of course now that
theme is like my thing right like that
is my jam yeah so this is the things I'm
sorry yeah well you have to make fun of
it and no totally okay I have another
question
last one and they do have the Mikey do
you feel him anything anything like
what's your relationship with him now do
you have anything we're like oh my god I
think that was him I'm not one of those
people okay like I was with Heather
McMann and her father wrestling viously
passed away and we were in Malibu and
she saw B and she was like hi dad like
they're the B is like a symbolic thing
for her I don't have that and that's not
that I don't believe in it I just don't
have a thing like obviously whenever I
see Lou Combs wearing like a big fishing
t-shirt oh my god that's what daddy used
to wear like certain clothing certain
clothing reminds me but I don't have
like a it's a portal into you know a
Long Island medium especially now it's
been like over ten years so it feels
more distant but I feel like there are
moments where like we're all celebrating
or like something good as happy yeah
it's like you know just like our whole
families to go
it's like he's we can like we just know
he's like right there like yeah like we
all got married all three of us like in
the last year and a half two years and
like that I feel like as I got older I
start to miss him more like it didn't
get better it got worse it's like I when
I was in high school I think it like
care I'm like whatever parents so yeah
but it's like now it's like I'm getting
married like I've [ __ ] on my dad here
I'm like seeing Ben get have both his
parents like you're so unfair
totally that's unfair no I know I get it
was your mom at your wedding no supper
two best friends what you know oh that's
so nice
that's really soon and then how I
believe like she was totally there like
yes totally yeah and we had like little
things like Jewish things like that you
know but I'm not one of those people
who's like I feel his ghost inside me
you know like oh my god wait give me
other night I'm a dad yeah you I'm not
one of those people but I believe in it
yeah you know I'm happy for people that
you have this I'm sure you're sick like
to take of this question so you can tell
you literally just released an album
that I'm sure you put like your entire
heart and soul to like like we expect
new music I know I'm already writing new
stuff good the beginning of next year
for sure is like going into full-on
writing mode again yeah and it's I'm
excited I think I got so close that our
have you or would you ever do at CMT
cross over cross crossroads crossroads I
feel like it'd be great great yeah the
country thing is like so interesting
yeah because we're huge country music
you guys it's big country music I love
country music I didn't really grow up
listening to it very much and then you
know just randomly one of my biggest
songs could be almost good misconstrued
his country's history country is not
even country to me country is just good
music and then would you do like a like
a crossover with the with the Eli Young
Band that did go on like a duet with
them but yeah I think some people
sometimes go like right what do you
consider yourself to be summarize
songwriter yeah
do you watch song land yes so you would
be great on it it's a great show you
know my wife did some she like worked on
that show really we had it's such a good
show and they do a podcast you they
really I think it would be a great judge
and also a great artist to go on E and
get a song yeah cuz you are a songwriter
Oh
I had I was listening to your song on
the way over here oh my god I'm
embarrassed did you like oh good it's
just like honestly I'd love to Sagan
like while I didn't really make it as a
singer like why should that stop me from
putting out a song like what literally
shouldnt like use to be a popstar
releases you know no no and like this
show needs a song what we need a theme
song and then just like I can be used
like music in a lot of our content and
like copyright these days like it's just
so tough we need jobs you don't even
need to do what you're doing right now
love it I love that yes and what I want
to do is while we're in this space is
tell you like just keep making sounds oh
really cuz I wasn't sure I wasn't sure
if I should like just have released a
song because like I did it and we can
look back and be like damn that was such
a cool thing that I did or if I should
like continue like am I gonna release an
album
I don't know like so much of it of the
game is thinking that you want to do
something having your brain go like hey
I like music right and that's like makes
music do you find like the more
successful like the more accolades you
get like the more self-conscious you
become good question self-conscious more
in your own head there's more pressure
that like this art that you're making
that you hopefully are just making
because you want to make it what I say
is like it is a battle to when you're
being artistic to create out of joy
rather than fear when you create from
fear it ends up sounding like derivative
because you're trying to make it fit in
with something as opposed to being like
oh man I want to go make this I'm so
excited to make yeah you know that
really reminds me of an important
question I wanted to ask you I would
love to hear your thoughts on one Taylor
Alison Swift I just I feel like you as a
songwriter would really respect her and
I'm hoping I'm hoping that were on the
same page
she's amazing okay she's brought me on
stage twice oh yes 1989 tour I wrote her
lyric myra lyrics down her arm she like
really gave me a boost
in my early career what did you guys
sing on tour we say keep your head up
the first time and then she brought me
out in Chicago I like in her Stadium I'm
good wait that's so crazy she's uh she's
really incredibly generous yeah and like
she's her like platform platform and
light and everything yes oh my god I
love that I totally forgot him so glad I
asked you that question maybe what's
that so crazy like to me on the stadium
in Chicago
yeah it was really really cool and
surreal and and also just like
impressive to see someone who who's up
that high that like just every time I've
seen her I got the play for she just did
the Billboard with your speech I think
the first time she got a woman of the
year I covered one of her songs Wow
before she gave her speech right and
every time she gives this speech she's
really good at putting it back to
everybody else right which is what you
want yeah like not like a self-absorbed
yeah yeah it's so funny we all just want
to hear about ourselves well yeah and
when the light is shining on someone
else all we want in the audience is like
just tells me yeah it's all about me wow
that's amazing I totally forgot that you
did that that was such a crazy time in
pop culture when she was just like
reading people on and I'm so glad that
you were there it's a really cool thing
it's just like a cool thing to have done
you know then it's a win for everybody
hopefully right but still even so that
doesn't happen a lot no and not with
people who are like at that level a
superstar like cool paying it forward I
love her okay so everyone has to follow
Andy Grammer on Instagram listen to his
podcast it sounds great I'm gonna go
home and listen to oh my good um if you
haven't listened to the album yet it is
so good what are you doing I make you
like cry and like want to start a family
but also like live the life to the point
like yeah and yet that's the thing about
your music it's like I will never forget
I have done SoulCycle
um three times in my life great yeah and
I don't like it but I did a class and
she played honey I'm good and you just
don't consider any grammar like
SoulCycle music but I was there and I
was like I'm good it's really bad it's a
great song it's like a perfect beats per
minute for SoulCycle like everyone
should cycle to it and that's just like
the diversity and be loved in an artist
and like we have no choice but to stand
we have absolutely no choice thank you
so much for coming here thank you for
contributing such positive vibes in the
world and keep bringing those kids with
you because they're so cute so much
thank you guys for the same hope you
have a great table see you tomorrow
you